the hunter hunter Iceberg goes even
deeper than you thought to be honest it
goes even deeper than I thought when I
first started putting all of this
together I thought this was just going
to be like a fun compilation of weird
facts but the depth of this world is so
ridiculous and we are going to start
with something that blew my mind quite
literally if he could because it's
getting through the antagonist best
remembered as the one everyone forgets
but did you know that gentru's very
existence was foreshadowing a massive
part of the Chimera antarct specifically
with his nanability little flower which
allows gen through to create small bomb
detonations within the palm of his hand
which is very similar both in name and
effect to the miniature rose used by
Isaac netro against marijuana but also
used by warring Nations all over the
world the miniature rose was banned but
it was still a very common and easy to
use weapon so the history here is that
at some stage in his life again through
witness the detonation of a miniature
rose and he was so enamored with its
beauty and destruction that he came up
with his own pocket version of it and
named it Little Flower sort of like
going to the Eiffel Tower and then
buying a smaller shittier Eiffel Tower
from one of of the various scam artists
on the street don't buy those don't
encourage them but on the topic of
landmarks let's head to Dubai
specifically the Burj Khalifa a building
which should look very familiar because
it is the spitting image of Heaven's
Arena did you know that the Burj Khalifa
was actually the inspiration for
heaven's Arena if so you're wrong and
we're going to unlearn that right now
because the truth is even stranger
despite often being credited as the
design inspiration by very terribly put
together online facts lists Heaven's
Arena actually predates the Burj Khalifa
by half a decade with tagashi first
pending the building in 1999 and
Construction in Dubai commencing in
2004. and all I'm saying is whichever
Prince was in charge of this project
they might have been a big fan of
fictional Hunters oh and in case you're
wondering which is taller the Burj
Khalifa stands at 830 meters tall whilst
Heaven's arena is a mighty 991 meters
tall so those score one for tagashi and
nil for the nation of Dubai you'll move
Dubai meanwhile for those of you keeping
scoring goongi you'll have noticed a
simply mind blowing piece of information
regarding marowam and komogi's games and
information being that their gunky
matches basically tell us the entire
Palace Invasion story before it happens
and it's all due to the kokoriko
strategy this was a play independently
thought up by marowen which had
previously been invented by komogi the
idea of which is to separate the king
from the other pieces and then
mercilessly destroy said King thus
winning the game match which is exactly
the same strategy used by netro and the
extermination team to deal with marowen
that is how marowen perfectly understood
netro's intentions because he'd already
seen and used it himself in goongi but
it goes much deeper than that whilst
playing comedy actually comes up with a
counter to kokoriko thus saving her King
and so during the palace invasion
marowen was also saved after kokorika
was used on him the games that marowam
and komogi had previously played are
governing this entire series of events
so here's where things get slightly
complicated and Incredibly tragic later
on Comedy uses kokoriko against marowam
who plays the count strategy but then
komogi develops a counter counter
strategy thus ensuring the demise of the
king to kokorika once more and this is
exactly what happened in the palace
Invasion marowam counted the miniature
rose by absorbing his Royal Guards
giving them various strange anti-orgasms
but that in turn was counted by the
poison of the Poor Man's Rose and there
is so so much more gunky symbolism in
this Arc so much that it would need an
entire video of its own to explain it
all but these scenes are far from random
every single move by every single piece
in gungi is something that Togashi
painstakingly thought about now did I
hear somebody say sex doll no are we
going to talk about it anyway Mr
military zoldik is probably the least
developed of the siblings however if
there's one thing that absolutely cannot
be ignored it is the life-size Anime
Girl doll in his room actually to be
fair I suppose it's only an anime God to
us because Hunter Hunter is an anime to
milliki it's just a regular guy now what
most people tend to focus on is the
standing upright girl the one with a
skirt shorter than leorio's temper
however I would actually like to draw
everyone's attention to the other dolls
sitting a bit more hidden away in the
corner there the one more blatantly how
shall we say adult oriented and just in
case there was any doubt as to the
purpose of these dolls then just bear in
mind that they appear in chapter number
69. now that's what I call a real snake
in the shower right no it's not but this
is in the 1999 anime we are I'm going to
use the word treated to a wide variety
of bathing scenes during the hunter exam
one of which is ponzu and she had a
special guest being one of bourbon
snakes I actually think this bit of
filler is pretty brilliant because it
gives a nice comic setup to the eventual
tragedy which is of course when ponzu
and bourbon get trapped in a cave with
bourbon being killed by ponzu's bees and
ponzu being unable to leave due to
Bourbon snakes sometimes the 1999 anime
was really good at setting up stuff like
this but at other times it was just
weird such as the notorious case of
gone's mini boat from episode 1 because
while in the manga and in the 2011 anime
gone boards a larger transport vessel to
leave whale island in the 1999 anime
they elected to have him depart the
island on this teeny tiny boat thing
she's not absolutely mind-boggling
decision to look at in isolation it's
just such an unnecessary change however
the reason why they do this is because
of episode 2. like all incredibly strong
story-driven anime Hunter immediately
dives into a filler episode for its
second outing which involves gone
sailing to a new island in order to
leave his small boat to board a bigger
boat saying it out loud it actually
sounds a lot like one piece especially
since gone's mini boat strongly evolves
those baratier mihawk vibes but in this
filler episode they rewrite the story of
how gone meets leori who is also on the
island and then it goes on to flirt with
some darker aspects of Hunter Hunter as
gon is almost abducted by an implied
pedophile gone's bugging leoria to tell
him where the ship is leori is just like
he's having none of it and then this guy
this guy with the dodgy mustache just
comes out of nowhere and he's like come
with me little boy I'll tell you where
the ship is and then he takes gone by
the hand Leora gives him a bit of a
thwack in a very uncomfortable scene
comes to an end but basically that is
why gon's mini boat exists because we
needed that leoria filler episode where
gone was almost abducted by a strange
man in a van so the moral of the story
is don't trust strangers unless it's
Leorio who was also a stranger at the
time but also don't trust Hunter Hunter
data books if you're unaware these are
standard Publications for all
long-running Shonen series that compile
information about the characters the
world and expand on all of them in
generally insightful ways for example
the one piece starter books tell you
almost as much about the story as the
actual series does or is the Hunter
Hunter data books primarily exist to
confuse the issue is that these are not
written by tagashi himself so they often
go on to contradict the series for
example both Zeno and silver zaldic are
traditionally thought of as transmuters
and that's because that's what the data
book said they were however this was
directly contradicted by Togashi himself
who stated that they were emitters and
then there's the names my God the names
in the data book karapika's name is
officially spelled as Kara picked
uvergine's name is spelled word Burger
green and my personal favorite crawler
Lucifer whose official name according to
the data book and I want you all to
refer to him as this from now on is cool
Ralph rossifer not even machi's name is
safe having been spelled Mighty call my
team yet anyway speaking of Machi not
being safe weird thing now she is
actually supposed to be dead very very
dead in the extra comments of volume 36
Togashi expands heavily on the aftermath
of crawler vs hisoka and his wording
here is quite interesting what I wanted
to do most was have him him being hisoka
kill someone in the truth I knew how the
story was going to work out but I hadn't
decided who hisoku would kill at the end
hisoka wanted to kill Machi then and
there but I vetoed it which firstly is
it's a very interesting way of talking
about your story as if Togashi is having
an actual discussion with one of his
characters he knew what hisoka wanted
but Togashi as some sort of supreme
storytelling man kind of blue bolty
Soaker again because and I quote it was
my hunch that letting Machi stick around
would make it much more interesting for
later on so for all intents and purposes
Machi should be dead but Togashi had a
feeling of feeling deep within his
narrative loins and now Machi is still
alive for a reason that he may or may
not have decided yet and the unknown
decisions don't stop there because one
of the biggest Legacy mysteries of
Hunter Hunter has always been the two
missing members of the Phantom Truth The
Troop when fully formed consists of 13
people each numbered from 0 to 12. and
the makeup of the troop look it's
changed pretty significantly over the
course of the series but we have never
actually seen the full 13. sorry I
should say we have never actually seen
the original full 13 by which I'm
talking about number eight a member
stated to have been killed by Silver's
older and number four a member whose
spot was usurped by hisoka tagashi is
very careful to not necessarily specify
that number four was killed however when
this horny battle clown is involved I
don't say that's a fair assumption these
two missing members basically only exist
in a void of History because we very
recently received a phantom troop
flashback detailing the origin story of
the group in meteor City however these
two members were not present at that
time meanwhile we also know what the
troop goes on to become and it just
feels like we're missing a very integral
piece of this here true puzzle who were
these two enigmas how did they get
involved with the troop and why was
Silva zeldick hired to assassinate one
of them funnily enough all we know about
this is that Silva said the money wasn't
worth it which means that whoever that
number eight was was pretty damn
powerful someone well worth knowing
about in the history of this series
which we don't know about and
potentially never will meanwhile there
is a common belief that the original
number four is omakage from The Phantom
Rouge film and while that is probably
the better of the two Hunter Hunter
films they're both just as non-canon and
so the true Original Number Four Still
Remains a mystery honestly one of the
things I really want from Hunter Hunter
before tagashi inevitably ends it for
good is just to know who these two
people are but failing that I also
really want the Greed Island game which
is a goal you can actually achieve
because Bandai did actually make a
physical version of the Greed Island
card game which came with a player's
binder and an accompanying joystation
box getting your hands on one of these
is not easy and they're pretty damn
pricey these days but the biggest
problem is that owning the cards doesn't
actually allow you to play the Greed
Island game in any way shape or form
because that's just not possible
probably for the best when you consider
that it has cards like pregnancy Stone
but you're essentially buying a
glorified prop but it's still pretty
damn cool meanwhile in World Greed
Island holds one of the greatest meta
mysteries in Hunter Hunter because every
now and then in the series you'll notice
an object or location featuring these
almost alien-like inscriptions the Box
Jing left forgone for example was sealed
with multiple sticks covered with these
inscriptions this is such a criminally
underexplored aspect of Hunter Hunter
but these are specific codes designed to
enhance nen when applied to an object
and you can find examples of
inscriptions being used absolutely
everywhere at its earliest Point wing
used inscription on the strings tied
around gone's finger programming the
string to break if gone used 10.
meanwhile the handcuffs nov uses to
remain bound to his hide and seek he
also have inscription applied and in the
more modern day the hunter Association
have applied another set of handcuffs to
be on netro featuring inscription which
I imagine is really the only possible
way to detain nen users without using an
actual ability but inscription gets a
lot crazier than that because these
these are all sort of fun utility uses
so far basically program nen code into
object for desired effect but the
entirety of Greed Island operates from a
central Hub of inscription the whole
opening room is absolutely slathered in
end programming to ensure that
day-to-day operations of the island a
feat that we've recently seen equaled by
King nasabi's burial chamber an absurdly
massive room featuring 14 coffins for 14
corpses and when these coffins are
finally all filled what we are going to
witness is likely one of the grandest
scale extreme uses of Nan that we have
ever seen in the series because these
patterns are not random it's programming
language understood by only those at the
very Heights of nenus we as readers
haven't even begun to comprehend the
depth of what's Happening Here and in
fact what's been happening in the world
all along but with that said net
inscription isn't even the most secret
nen language in the series there is an
even more hidden and potentially even
more powerful script that we've already
seen in the story which I'm going to
Showcase in the next video because we
are still nowhere near the true depths
of this iceberg